quelle place pour les trottinettes
électriques en ville la mort la semaine
dernière à tour d'une femme percutée par
un camion relance le débat la
circulation des trottinettes électriques
et désormais encadrée par le code de la
route alors comment se passe la
cohabitation notamment avec les piétons
vous voyez ce reportage rue national de
la Turquie
en centre ville de Tours on peut croiser
tous types voitures piétons vélo et
tramway cohabitent et en complément de
plus en plus de trottinettes électriques
un sujet qui fait débat moi ça me
dérange pas sauf que parfois je suis un
peu surprise quand ils arrivent derrière
moi donc ma fille se comporte bien il y
a pas de problème doit pouvoir
s'entendre ça va trop vite c'est
toujours bon je sais pas c'est quand
même c'est dangereux quoi peut-être s'il
y avait une piste rien que pour les
trottinettes ça peut être mieux car la
zone réservée aux trottinettes
électriques c'est la route ou les pistes
cyclables du côté des utilisateurs ce
mode de transport est privilégié pour
son côté pratique rapide et sans
efforts et tu t'en vas et comme quand tu
connais une voiture toujours être
prudent je le fais gaffe et bon bah je
suis assez prudente déjà je suis une
conductrice donc je sais ce que c'est
donc en trottinette je fais la même
chose comme si j'étais en voiture pour
circuler en toute sécurité il faut
effectivement appliquer quelques règles
essentiel entre autres pas d'écouteurs
dans les oreilles ne pas transporter de
passagers et une vitesse maximale
possible de 25 km/h sur la voie publique
et encore moins dans des lieux très
fréquentés
dans une zone de rencontre comme la rue
Nationale une trottinette doit être doit
limiter sa vitesse à 8 km/h alors c'est
difficile d'estimer 8 km/h mais c'est la
vitesse de quelqu'un qui marche plutôt
vite le tout c'est comme tous les moyens
de déplacements des utilisés avec en
faisant attention aux autres à noter que
circuler en trottinette électrique sur
le trottoir et passible d'une amende de
135 euros